I recently co-authored a study which
reported that contrary to conventional
wisdom school reformers today are
overwhelmingly left-leaning now every
movement requires some agreement on core
beliefs or isn't a movement two decades
ago though the litmus test for school
reformers was pretty inclusive it held
that schools could do much better that
all kids could learn and that this
probably involved some role for choice
and accountability today the striking
thing is how all-encompassing and
ideologically divisive those core
beliefs have become in school reform
circles it often seems that reformers
take their lead from those who insist
that being an agent of educational
improvement requires one to think
correctly about a host of issues
including white privilege that causes of
poverty gun control taxation and much
more a meaningful school reform
coalition can and must encompass those
who have good faith disagreements about
these questions that makes finding a way
to revisit these litmus tests both a
pressing challenge and a rich
opportunity for school reformers what
core principles do you think should
guide school reform let us know in the
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI